it's not easy for me to say this but I
have a problem and I'm not the only one
there are thousands millions of people
around the world that suffer from the
same affliction the same uncontrollable
urges the same Drive and alienates as
many people as it attracts but staying
silent isn't going to help anyone
so I need to say this out loud I love
puns
I love puns I love good puns I love bad
puns I really love making puns there's
anyone who knows they will attest I love
the delete reaction they get I love the
way they upend a conversation and after
spending some time inside the world of
pun competitions I've seen the best and
the worst of what wordplay has to offer
so come with me won't you for a look
inside of what just might be the most
divisive kind of performance since
improv comedy in San Francisco the Bay
Area pun off is a monthly event that's
been going on since the beginning of
2016 it's structured like the granddaddy
of the genre the O'Henry pun off World
Championship in Austin Texas is going on
for 40 years now
the first part of the night is reserved
for people to perform pre-written
fun-filled monologue let's dinosaurus
but the main event is something called
fun sliders in which a theme is
announced and then people make
spur-of-the-moment puns on that theme
until their opponent flames out the
nerdiest freestyle battles what you call
like a party in the morning for a brick
that humor theorists generally agree
that there are four types of parties
there are homonyms which rely on one
word having more than two meetings
anyone here from Cleveland seriously I'm
gonna be the only one so I'm I'm super
excited for football season I like to
follow I use Twitter a lot so if you're
a fan like I am just look for hash
browns
there are homophones which are two words
that are spelled differently but sound
identical
there are homographs in which two words
look similar or identical even but they
sound very very different now these work
much better as visual puns you're almost
never going to hear these out loud you
might see them on signs and bobs burgers
or something like that for example
imagine a surrealist play about 80s toys
waiting for go box see I told you they
all work out loud and then there are
parents which are words that vaguely
sound like other words this is the
fuzziest type of pun but it's also the
thing that leads to some of the funniest
one really want to get married want to
get married now but too much respect for
my parents so I can't below it's also
the bedrock of punting or as linguists
know it pairen amnesia you know standing
up here and looking at the sartorial
choices that we've all made I realized
that I never wear anything with jeans I
got to go out tomorrow and get a cup of
tea knows but with a little bit of luck
and a very very forgiving audience you
might be able to put them all together
to elevate bad jokes to high art or at
least find some people feeling generous